good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday to bruno and
bruno only that's right the rumors are
true bruno has made it to the toast you
guys he's so excited to be here i'm so
excited to have him i'm so proud of him
this far in the way that he's behaving
and carrying himself and really showing
how good of a boy he really is 100
he's very influenced by dew i think that
brew has been watching the show in his
down time and he sees what dude does
around looks up to him and he's really
just a do stand-in brew is looking so
sexy so cute popular taboo bitchin
great hair the boys all love to stare
um so thank you for bringing him i know
it's a journey especially in the rain
when you texted i'm bringing brew i'm
like there's no way because theo even if
bruno wasn't coming i was not breaking
theo today because the rain is just so
annoying oh interesting well my thought
process was it's been about i think nine
days since bruno since july yeah so it's
nine days of lies so like obviously
everybody's waiting for me to stop lying
we need to get a chalkboard it's been
one day since jackie lied zero days yes
today we're crossing it out it's in zero
days since you lied um you did lie to us
yesterday
yeah we all hung out yesterday and you
were like i'm bringing bruno and you
showed up sans bruno i know because i
was too concerned because of the rain
and like i was just too concerned it
wasn't worth him being everywhere but
today i was like oh it is raining and
also i wasn't like crazy about bringing
him on monday because we have so much
like work to do and catching up he's so
distracting so i don't need him like
running over to mcplant he's better he's
so distracted like i'm not even looking
at you by the way right that's like
friday stuff so anyways i was like i'll
bring him tomorrow but he actually um
is getting room tomorrow morning he's
busy at spa services so he can't join us
tomorrow and i was like i can't go like
11 days of bruno's mom lying no you
can't be 11 days of a liar no so brew
came today and i'm so glad that he did i
mean he was really nervous to come here
he was nervous and excited because he
was crying and uh wagging his tail so
that's like he's happy and sad at the
same time and i think now that he's here
i mean he knows mommy never brings him
anywhere torturous and i think he feels
comfortable here this is a nice space
it's a safe space no definitely but i
think he was like where are we going
what are we doing he didn't see this for
himself today yeah well the agoraphobia
will do that to you yeah plus like
it's raining like it just it threw him
off his schedule speaking of angry was a
major topic of discussion this weekend i
want to make sure everyone's okay here
in the city we're fine i did see some
videos of like brooklyn being like a
little flooded but for the most part we
were okay yeah i don't know about
everyone else so just watch out i
haven't seen
anything like too destructive but i also
haven't seen that much yeah because i
haven't watched the local news i've just
kind of been sidetracked with the only
of it all like such a weird name no i
love the name for the hurricane aubry
yeah it's like henry grew up on long
island and then went traveled abroad for
semester and now he's already yeah
sickly name it is kind of a sickening
name and actually inspired us to do a
little research yesterday on
where hurricane names come from and
i always thought that the country of
origin got to name the cane based in
alphabetical order as we all know but no
apparently the world meteorological
service organization has a like a six
lists of names that they cycle through
so that like this year we're going
through a list that was also used in
2015 so if some of the names sound
familiar it's because they are which
just doesn't seem like so unnecessary it
just doesn't seem like the best way to
go about it and i don't know i feel like
it's never too late to change you know
what you've been doing i feel like you
were also telling me that certain names
what if they're really destructive
hurricanes get required get retired yes
very destructive hurricanes the names
get retired because like you know
everyone associates it as one hurricane
if you're like of course blank is coming
and everyone's like so obviously
katrina's been retired what about sandy
i was thinking sandy might be retired
yeah
sandy was weird because like in certain
parts of
the city it was like completely fine and
then five blocks down like it was
underwater it was so crazy yeah but it
was really destructive for new jersey
yes jersey shore so i have to now look
into which ones have been retired but i
don't know i think we could use like a
little bit more
creativity when it comes to the
hurricane names and i would like to
nominate the people who name the opi
nail polish
geniuses to name hurricanes geniuses
just something to think about i like
that idea very much i support that
legislative like they just have a list
six lists that they keep cycling through
that makes no sense no and like each
hurricane is an individual like they
deserve their own name it is there's no
reason that we should have two hurricane
you know beatrice's whatever yeah that
does sound like a name they would you
know earlier this year i guess it didn't
get a lot of um
i guess it wasn't extremely strong there
was hurricane claudette you're kidding
earlier this year
that's what they call me when i leave
the bar yeah she is the hurricane oh my
god interesting my name's sake i should
have paid more attention yeah but it
wasn't such a big deal they will respond
obviously didn't make a splash no
she never does
um i have to tell you that like i
finally picked up my kindle this weekend
i saw that you did i feel so warm and
fuzzy inside like knowing that you had a
kindle filled weekend it was great i
actually had like
balance this weekend which is so crazy
i relaxed a lot i saw a lot of family i
spent so much time with michaela my
heart my cup is truly full like truly um
but i also went out i hit the clubs i
read like it was perfect balance i'm so
happy for you would you like to share in
some of the content that you consumed i
read regretting you by colleen hoover
and i love coho like most of her books i
would say like verity
um
it was
it ends with us
november nine most of her books that
i've read ugly love i loved very do you
like that i said that yeah loved five
stars
i literally said verdi was the first one
i said like rewind
i don't know if she did i said i'm like
listening intently no i said it okay
whatever so i've read a lot of books one
what was the one hopeless hated trash so
it appears if you're above 18. yeah so
it appears to me that coho has like two
different genres of books and one is
like for adults and one is for teenagers
and i think the one that i read
regretting you
was
for teenagers even though it's like kind
of steamy
it was so
cringy like i'm bad and i got invested
in it rather quick because there's a big
twist in the beginning
and then like there's no other twists so
it was just like suffering the
consequences of the twist yeah and i
finished it just because like i had to
but oh my god it got so much worse at
the end you just like hate all the
characters they're all being so dumb
um so i did not like that i didn't and i
feel annoyed that like that you came
back to reading and that's what you read
no i just feel annoyed that like the
coho like
she almost like disappointed me a little
bit you know but you know there's a pot
for every kettle and this was just not
my book yeah a cover for every pot yeah
so then what happened i started people
we meet on vacation i'm only like ten
percent in um i always had to watch
potomac last night it's cute okay i told
you not to read it because i personally
didn't like it but you know what i would
love to hear your thoughts the thing is
like i'm now on my third book
recommendation from tick tock the first
was we were liars or something yeah
hated
literally the first couple chapters are
introducing the people in the book and
there must be 50 of them how is anyone
supposed to remember that many people
then i my second one was
regretting you which i hated right and
now my third is people we meet on
vacation and if i hate it i'm done
taking recommendations from book talk i
think that's good because we have such a
great community i mean obviously the
redheads but like within the toasters
you there's just such a great community
of readers
you should be able to get
recommendations from the group can i
just tell you that like you making me or
not making recommending when you're on
vacation last year to read the seven
husbands of evelyn hugo it's like the
best thing you ever did for me let me
tell you why okay
because like first of all it's a book i
think about all the time like i actually
might even read it again like that's how
good it is
but also because like
a bunch of my friends like who are like
into reading like not most normal people
don't read as much as you right so
they'll read like the best book of the
year like most people probably read
where the chronicles yeah so most people
don't like actively keep up like with
with the new cool books so whenever
people are like talking about books
finally i can first of all join the
conversations yeah and two i'm like have
you read the seven husbands of evelyn
hugo and they're like no what's that and
i'm just like i love giving people like
a life-changing book that i know is like
10 out of 10. i'm sure there are people
out there who didn't like it but like
for the most part everyone loved it and
like i get to be that person you know
like an intellectual superior person
yeah be like oh try this i think you'll
like it did you read malibu rising you
know i started it and i thought that i
didn't like it i just wasn't even pulled
into it at all
i'll pick back up but it's not on my
to-do list got it well i had a huge
weekend of content as well that i just
like to run through i watched the show
hacks like i said that i won finally
and
i enjoyed most of the show because it
was really great and the um
the older comedian
was the best was the best and she's
everything of the sort but we had to
suffer through the younger community i
know
and that was our cross to bear because
she was insufferable the worst the worst
so i enjoyed the show very much but i
would say however much percentage the
younger girl was in it took away from
took away from the glory of the show
okay i just wanna i was just googling it
to make sure so i was wondering first of
all like why this girl got the job on
like this hbo show
um and of course like her mom is super
famous you know okay her mom is like
formerly on snl lorraine newman
she's uh
whatever she's famous so i'm like she
wasn't that great of an actress i'm like
why did she get this job in a show that
was like obviously really well thought
out yes that makes me feel better that
like it wasn't because she you know
because she's talented yeah
she just but also i mean the actress
herself she's fine but like the
character she was playing was so irksome
like atrocious and it's just like listen
to deborah vance like shut up
not fully thought opinions like deborah
has the answers shut up okay but
honestly for me like one of the
highlights of the show was the agent's
assistant
she was everything i feel like this is
going to be like a breakout role for her
i follow her on tick tock i'm not sure
like how she got started but i know she
has like a big digital persona she's so
funny on tick tock she is just as
hysterical i love her i think her name
is meg stalter she is really funny in
the show but like obviously her
character is annoying yeah but she i
agree she was a very good character um
so i enjoyed hacks
i did thank you i'm glad that i watched
it i'm really clearing off this content
plate are you thinking that the show is
inspired by joan rivers not the show but
the character of deborah yeah like the
plot for the show is just clearly like a
good idea like old and young coming
together but like the grandeur of the
way that deborah lives her life you know
sort of
the story of where she was sort of like
blacklisted from late night yes is very
joan having like this tragic past with
her husband is very joan yeah so i think
deborah was modeled off and also like
being the og queen of comedy like
roseberry jones but joan didn't do vegas
like joe didn't work with a young writer
at the end of her life this isn't like
the story of jones but like they
definitely were influenced by joan do
you think there's gonna be a second
season slash does there like need to be
yeah it's open to a second season
because she sent that email right um
i wish they didn't have that because it
would have been like a perfect mini
series yeah but we'll see i would watch
another season but like that actress who
played joan was hysterical like i just
was the writing was very good yeah she
was great um so i really enjoyed that
then i decided to read because i didn't
want to just like just be watching tv
all weekend so i read the personal
librarian which has been like very
popular i've seen it like at every
airport that i've been at it's a
historical fiction book it's about
jp morgan's personal librarian so that
was just like a fun time but it's about
the woman who was in charge of the
morgan ladders right she the library
doesn't have morgan ladders at least not
when she was curating it but throughout
the book she's writing ladders
therefore they are the morgan ladders it
was so morgany
the book was so morgany like i really
have a pretty good sense of that period
in the morgan family history and now you
feel like going to the morgan library
right i do feel like going to the morgan
library i wonder because the book is
really popular i wonder if they're
getting like a surge of interest 100
um because it's just right here in new
york and that's like a pretty cool thing
about living in new york like a lot of
the times in the books that we read like
the thing that they're talking about is
just down the street it's on 36th and
madison right like you could just go and
see it so that's pretty cool
one point for new york today
very small it happened 100 years ago
um no but i passed that building before
and i'm like that's stunning like
someone should get married there yeah
and i'm like what is the morgan library
but it's a thing it's a thing and the
book was amazing and the story of um the
personal librarian belle de costa green
is an amazing story and so i really
enjoyed the book and i read it in like
two days and it was historical fiction
but like a true story i still don't know
what to call
books about real people though the
the story is like fictionalized because
they're they don't know the
conversations they're like extrapolating
from other you know what i mean i don't
know yeah i don't know what to call that
either anyway so i finished that and
then i started a new book last night
called rules of civility by amar tolls
dana had read it and she gave it a high
rating so i was like okay and i'm
enjoying it so that's good
did you make time to watch the friday
episode of the morning toast with me
josh and shannon
i i did catch some of it but it hurt too
much okay you know and you did tell me
like the pertinent bits of information
but it just i'm so happy that they were
here and that they had such an amazing
time and you had such an amazing
conversation with them i'm just so sad
that i couldn't be there i have to say i
do think that's like top five one of my
favorite guests one because like of
course when we interview people i'm
super interested in them but like i've
never been so invested in anything in my
life like i was love island right right
i'd like to see to like have if i could
have chosen any two people it would have
been them right so cute in person by the
way they gave so much tea on the show
and then also like after the show they
gave me even more tea which
unfortunately i cannot share but let me
just tell you it's wild um and i
literally like would not let them leave
without taking like spritz merch shannon
left here with like a new hoodie she was
wearing a new phone case i gave them
morning chose condoms i gave them
morning toast face masks um the girl who
one of uh josh's really good friends who
was the girl running his social like
this entire time like you have to chew
they were saying like yes shannon paid
her sister to do it josh's friend like
offered to do it um his friend is a huge
toaster so then i was like take this for
alex like i was like clearing out our
whole thing yeah it looks nice no it's
empty i gave them everything um it was
really just like the best and i really
was trying so hard not to talk over them
because i feel like when we do guest
interviews you usually temper the
conversation like
because i'm an animal but you weren't
here to do that so like i just got to be
an animal no i think i actually did a
good job of like tempering myself and
like holding i
read rave reviews about your performance
i read them too and it really made my
day they were really raped so um i'm
just so excited so glad that we can put
a button on love island you know i feel
like so many of our learning questions
were answered and then today is you know
another episode of bachelor in paradise
and i'm just not feeling motivated but
i'm not feeling motivated to do anything
but i just don't think it's gonna happen
it's gonna work for me yeah i feel you
about not being motivated to do anything
i just like woke up this morning and
it's like still doom and gloom and i'm
just like and i think we both looking at
our outfits like we both haven't thought
i'm done with summer officially it's
fall this slow ride out of august like
speed it up
needs to end it's fall i'm finished i
just want to say growing i think i've
said this a million times but growing up
is realizing that summer ain't [ __ ] like
you know as a kid it's like summer break
there's obviously so much to look
forward to camp no school two months no
homework
and then you just kind of keep that
energy up your whole life
but there comes a point when you realize
like summer sucks because yes the
weather is nice but we're still doing
the same [ __ ] we have to do in the
winter like low-key winter's the [ __ ]
yeah like you get home in the winter
after a long day of work you have no
desire to go outside you're cuddled up
cultivating a vibe appreciating nature
from inside but after a long day of work
you get home you're [ __ ] sweaty from
walking out in the heat
and then you get home and you're like oh
it's so nice i should do something but
you're [ __ ] exhausted so then you're
sitting inside wishing you were outside
honestly summer sucks yeah you heard it
here i agree totally looking forward to
falling into fall and i just want to let
everyone know that that's where i'm at
i'm not falling into fall i'm
steamrolling into fall like i'm [ __ ]
done i have put on leggings today and i
was like i haven't worn leggings in
forever and that's a disgrace because
leggings are my best friend yeah no i
had the same exact thought but i got
these ones with syrup so that's like a
crazy thing stir ups i thought they're
pretty cool when we were like kids like
syrups were everything they were so cool
people would cut their own stirrups like
into their lives
that was trashy
no but syrups i just think they are
super fall but that's what i'm saying
like you're falling into fall i'm
falling in to fall yeah [ __ ] off
falling into fall comma [ __ ] off love it
um okay so i guess without further ado
to do we can get into everything i just
want to give like one more shout out to
my best boy who i love so much i can't
believe he's here with me like the times
that we share together are so special
and private and intimate and to be here
like in the public and he's just like
doing his thing and and mommy's so proud
mommy's so proud mr brew do you want to
come here
my love's sweet
come why don't you go to your auntie
oh he swerved on me come here do you
love your empty that's a hard nail he's
exploring let him
he's got to see what's what's going on
here make sure it's up to code come here
he's the building inspector come here am
i gorgeous how do you guys
he's literally so distractingly sexy
it's like hard didn't i tell you it's a
hole and he walks around with this new
brew with this joadave it's it's a lot
to take in i'm not gonna lie i've been
trying to tell you but i'm glad that
you're experiencing it for yourself oh
also we're gonna have real housewives of
potomac recap this week uh
today i can't speak sorry um it was a
pretty good episode it wasn't as
explosive as i wanted it to be it was
good yeah it was an episode we've been
waiting for yes
okay without further ado
brew here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
that's true jax
that's true
but i would be remiss i would be
devastated and i would even be
heartbroken if i didn't let you know
that today's episode is brought to you
by betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
well betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line it is
not self-help it is professional therapy
and it's all done securely online the
service is available for clients
worldwide and you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist in return you will get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as you
do with traditional therapy better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today you can
visit their website and read all their
testimonials that are posted daily it's
betterhelp.com reviews and if you want
to get 10 off your first month go to
betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelphelp.com
toast to get 10 off and join the million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional betterhelp.com
slash toast
thank you for that claudia a pleasure
first story
in business with you
big news of the weekend caitlyn jenner
revealed another grandchild is on the
way but who's pregnant yeah so while
visiting the toy store in quincy
california on thursday the gubernatorial
hopeful opened up about her eighteen
grand i forgot that she's going for
governor still that's why she was doing
like at this point
speaking because it was a a um
a campaign trail i'm just confused about
caitlyn's schedule like i know she's
supposed to be or already is on
australia big brother
that must have ended because she's in
quincy california
but also australia's in lockdown maybe
like the show was canceled i don't know
i don't know either all we know is that
she was at the toy store
spilling the beans
unintentionally she opened up about her
18 grandkids and joked that she wanted
30 for the evenness of the number before
before confirming she'll soon have 19
grandchildren as one is in the oven so
of course everyone saw this and freaked
out because there's been so much
speculation about kylie confirmed this
rumor that's been swirling that kylie's
pregnant then they came out and said
that bert
one of caitlyn's sons is pregnant with
his wife and i think that's probably
true for sure because i don't think
caitlyn would spill the beans in this
way about kylie i mean i hope to god
caitlyn is not that stupid i don't think
that i don't think that she would but it
is shining a spotlight on what was
already like um you know something
people were whispering about and now
every single news outlet has come
forward and said that kylie is pregnant
yeah according to sources so i don't
know if that means that like kylie's
camp technically just confirmed it for
everyone so they would leave her alone i
don't think so to be honest like i hate
this so much
and like i don't know i didn't even like
post about it or anything i just feel
like people should be given the space to
announce their own pregnancy like that's
really all i feel and i just don't like
yeah and i know it just feels icky and i
also feel like kylie
is going to announce that she's pregnant
like whenever she's ready and whenever
it's time and i'm sure she has something
like and we didn't get that from her
first pregnancy and so i'm sure she's
going to be like publicly pregnant this
time and just like let her do it in her
way i'm sure she's some cool things
planned honestly i don't know if we're
going to see her publicly pregnant i
feel like from what i gather especially
at like um anytime they've done like a
reunion or anything or anytime kylie
talks about it she says like keeping it
low-key was like literally the best
thing for her body and she loved it she
loved that time in her life so much like
i could see her doing that for the next
pregnancy too i think it's different
because i think she was so young that
like she didn't want to even have to
deal with like a whisper of people's
thoughts about what she was doing i
think now that she's older she's already
a mom like i think that i don't think
she's gonna be like you know doing uh
clear blue sponsorships but i think like
she'll
we'll see her that would be crazy i
think she'll probably stay home because
she likes being home because that's
where she'll want to be if i had her
house i would like staying home too i
think we'll see her i i don't think it's
gonna be you know
nine months of old content and then and
then a vid a vlog the day after
i don't know i wouldn't be surprised
i wouldn't be surprised if she keeps it
like low-key again she like speaks about
that time with so much like reverend
because i think it was it was about that
particular moment moment and that
pregnancy and her age but she is like
nobody's questioning her now so no
that's true it doesn't have to be that
way well it's worth saying
congratulations to bert
justice for bert like everyone's like oh
it's just bert like no brook's having a
huge milestone congratulations bert
congratulations brooke the news here is
that bert is expecting congrats bert
it's really beautiful it's so happy for
bert right constantly being like
steamrolled over like yet again you know
yes though i do believe if you were to
ask me i do believe kylie's pregnant
i just feel like it's not i look forward
to finding out from here from hearing it
from her you know i feel like when kylie
dropped that vlog of stormy like
everyone remembers where they were it
was one of those moments to you because
i know exactly where it was in the back
of an uber no i don't remember oh i
guess it's not one of those moments yeah
i remember like what time of year it was
and everything oh it was like february
because that's when stormy lou's
birthday is got it
so what do you think this hypothetical
other child will be named do you think
we'll stick with a uh weather theme yeah
i think it'll be henry cloudy already oh
he is like studying except like when i
think of a young child with a french
name
of course i think of johann and francois
what was their last name mccord
no van kampen okay that's that's
francois van camp that flows a little
better yeah
those wonder what those kids are up to
now i i honestly
are like tick-tock famous the amount
that i think about them is
not healthy
they actually live in australia but also
in my mind yeah i hope they're doing
well
i'm sure you know they're thriving they
must be like have some sort of trauma
i think every kid who grows up on the
show like
i'm sure if we ask like avery singer or
like ali shapiro they have like trauma
stories just because it was like such a
weird time and it wasn't like a thing
now everyone has a reality show now but
back in the day it was like really kind
of like a spotlight i'm sure they all
have trauma but i don't i just feel like
francois and johannes is worse i don't
know i feel like fran suan johan like
have a thick skin you think i do and i
feel like they're not really like
affected by like pop culture they're
kind of like they do their own thing
yeah they lived in brooklyn they're
obviously very alternative yeah and i
just feel like they've never even heard
of real housewives of new york still
like they're just like you think they
have no idea they were on their show
honestly probably yeah they were so
young and they were only on for like
three years and they're just like doing
their own thing that would be hilarious
if they never knew except they show up
at school and there's obviously one
loudmouth [ __ ] who watched real
housewives he's like hi i'm francois van
campin and she's like from the real
housewives of new york
uh maybe i don't know i just feel like
they would just not they would just be
like okay
they wouldn't they wouldn't know i'm
telling you no i think you're taking it
too far no i'm telling you they don't
know they don't know and i am chilling
it just doesn't compute for them you
know okay
that's what i think okay ready for our
next story
sure taylor swift has joined tick tock
lip syncs to a rap song with lyrics
about her quote let the games begin
okay i love miss girl more than anything
like would truly take a bullet for her
but like
what was this video i do think that like
the transitions were meant to she was
showing her different eras like so at
first she was in her folklore then
evermore then we got her like dressed in
fearless and then we got a little sneak
peek of what she's gonna be looking like
for red and she has the bangs and the
red lipstick and she honestly looks like
she's 22 again like it's it's great but
this song like i don't know who sings
the song what is the significance it's a
rap song and she's singing like the 10
seconds where there's a song lyric about
being taylor getting business done
swiftly like who sings a song british
rapper dave and the song is called screw
face capital
it just felt like a very weird place to
start
yeah and i just feel like taylor nation
like which is her management team
there they have their own social medias
they have like a million followers
everywhere they've been on tick tock
this thus far
and everything they put out is like so
curated so like perfect it's really like
a great
content machine taylor nation and i just
feel like
they were obviously like managing this
emerging you know artist on tick tock
and i just feel like they dropped the
ball
well i feel like this is actually pretty
like
well like thought out and done for tick
tock where it's a little more on the fly
like you said like i remember when we
were doing tick tocks and you were like
nobody cares what you look like and it's
just more so like spur of the moment
that reminds me i have a tick tock we
need to film after this and i'm going to
need your help so just don't let me
forget okay i think brew got into
mcplant um so this already feels like
way more curated than like the tick
tocks that we see
but it's still not as curated as the
[ __ ] she usually posts which is like
made by a video editor like which i love
by the way like i'm ready for you know
taylor
raw yeah but i'm it's not even the
rawness i'm questioning it's the concept
like what is the song what is this what
is the point why are we all here yeah so
it didn't hit for you no but like of
course i watched it 1000 times and i
already followed her and i'm just
curious to see because like it's such a
big deal and she just did it right
before we started the show when i was
looking at her tic toc she had about 140
000 followers
and right now she has
245 wow that's like 100k in
like a minute
nice
so
yeah that's new with taylor
cool
are you ready for our next story is it
the final story not even close it's the
number three
wow we're moving slow today i know we
have a lot to say
you know what we will be singing that oh
give brew love if you show brew love
he'll give you everything in return hi
gorgeous
[Music]
i can honestly
fit brew like into anything that's all i
do when i listen to music
because honestly brew rhymes with you it
rhymes with doom no
literally my the one we sing the most is
i can't imagine my life without brew
i can't imagine one night without broom
honestly i'm like disappointed in myself
i've not listened to reverie me neither
what like for one iota of a second
either because i just don't trust ben
platt not to [ __ ] with me no i know and
like also i've just not been in a head
space i haven't been on a plane in the
windows yeah right oh
my friend abe texted me and he was like
i'm like on this plane right now he was
going out like he's like i'm so
emotional like happens to the best of us
i'm like just lean in but you know what
i will say like i do feel like you know
being emotional on a plane is just you
know part of being a human being but
i've never seen someone else on a plane
like crying in the window let me tell
you why because traveling is so
miserable like if you just saw someone
looking miserable you'd be like oh me
too like with a tear yeah because what
do you how close are you to their face
like if there's you're never crying like
sobs it's like maybe you'll tears though
maybe like one or two
i've never cried really more than one oh
oh then you haven't experienced no i
have then you have an experience but
also people like hide their faces when
they cry like they don't want to be seen
just look out for it i will check on
your fellow travelers for sure
come here brutal we gotta get into the
next story because it's some big news
what is it um mike richards is out as
the jeopardy host amid a cascade of
scandals okay so we reported last week
that mike richards who was formulated
the executive producer of jeopardy was
now going to be the host and we were
like really kind of jazzed about it and
i guess honestly i don't think we've
ever given like a news story that much
praise right and then
in reading more this weekend i'm pretty
sure we were the only ones who were
jazzed about it because not only does
has he like made um offensive comments
in the past and also like his workplace
behavior was
extremely sus oh
but people were not happy with the fact
that this person who was running the
contest
for who's gonna be the next jeopardy
host
the whole time like was in the running
himself
you know and they feel like maybe he
could have i mean i didn't read this
specifically but just reading between
lines they feel like he might have like
like sabotaged other of the guest hosts
like to make himself look better you
know and that they never really had a
chance you know i have to say like i was
going to come on here and say something
totally different first of all i didn't
know about his workplace conduct i just
know that he went on a podcast and said
something he had a podcast oh and he
like said something anti-semitic and
misogynistic and like as a jewish woman
i just like i just hate to like read
things people said eight years ago like
i just don't feel like it's reflective
of them and i hate like that we live in
a culture where it's like if you said
something eight years ago boom that's
your label today like i just don't like
it but hearing all this other
information especially about the
sabotage i first heard that he was out
because of like old comments i was like
okay this again but then i read there
was a whole long article i think was in
the ringer about like just him in
general and him as a boss and all this
stuff and then also the idea that he
didn't tell anyone like he was in the
running yeah and i guess like there was
also in reading in between the lines
that he was like
when we report on this article it's like
you never thought the guy behind the
camera no he's in front it's an american
apparently he's thirsty as [ __ ] oh
you're lying they didn't use those words
specifically but it's like he's he
wanted to host prices right like he
tried out for that drew carey got it
like he
well he must be
devastated to come so far and literally
you didn't even come close you got the
job yeah and then you [ __ ] it up yeah
oh interesting okay because you know i
was literally like thinking when when i
heard this story that i wasn't going to
talk about with josh and chan and i was
going to like wait for you and i was
going to have like a totally different
reaction but you're kind of persuading
me like no when i read the headlines
that was like i was like you know i
tweeted old tweets like
when you know this is just so so crazy
and then i read like more about just him
as a person and his conduct as a boss
and there was a lot yeah there was a lot
honestly i'm like so surprised that they
even chosen first of all abc is like so
buttoned up and jeopardy is like this
most prestigious show you would think
whenever they made an official decision
the person would be thoroughly vetted
and probably there were people like like
people on social media talking about
this before while he was still being
considered before it was officially
announced so you'd think that they would
have known about it but also
if they're vetting him like some of this
these things are just about him his
personality right there's no like like
paper trail no no not even that but like
the people who are vetting him like must
work with him like
if people in the office don't like him
like that should go towards his
yeah
so who's it gonna be i don't know back
to square one
literally mine bialik
i still
still i still would prefer if it's not
someone like who's famous famous already
like someone who's just straight
jeopardy forever vibes so there's also
the ken jennings of it all but ken
jennings has old tweets
like i'm sorry we are all humans like
everyone has old tweets like
but when people thought it was going to
be him like those tweets had resurfaced
and i guess they had surfaced many times
before because he's like kind of famous
before this whole thing and he's
addressed them and he says he keeps them
up like as a reminder to like show what
an [ __ ] he used to be which sounds
like something people say lie when they
get caught like taylor nolan said that
too remember she was like yeah i knew
about these atrocious tweets like i i
love them like she was like they remind
me every day how much how far i've come
like no like girls go through your
social media if there's one thing that's
even remotely offensive delete it like
people who say they keep up their old
tweets to remind them of how far they've
come are the biggest liars ever
just trust and believe okay
you know that's true 100 you know
it's a go-to excuse for someone who's
like no i've known about these it's not
like the go-to
but like it is like a crafty way of get
how dumb do they think we are
for real
i could let you know i had old tweets
and i did delete them and somebody had
screenshotted them before i deleted them
and
i didn't know that they were there i
deleted them okay yeah so i just hate
that but that's what ken jennings said
so even i don't even think they could
choose him now i just want to say like
based on what i read i think there's a
chance if it was just the comments made
on the podcast from 2013. they would
have been okay
not like it still would have
been a confusion
but it was like more than that it just
seemed to be like issues with him as a
person so ken jennings technically i'm
sure ken jennings is lovely
i i have to i refuse to believe anything
other than that but i also like i don't
know this man so like now like at first
i was like yes and now i read this
article i'm like no and i'm like you
know just a follower like yeah totally
you know what i mean so i don't like
who am i i have to meet mike richards
and then i'll decide what he's like yeah
i just it's so hard i know you know so i
guess but he's staying on as the
executive producer of the show which
probably is so painful for him
oh my god seeing someone else literally
right in front of you living your dreams
it's better than like losing your whole
job in your career that's true you know
could have gone that way too been there
done that
yeah
so
now i'm like confused with where i stand
yeah and like
where do they go from here when does
jeopardy come back they've got to like
hustle
i don't know
like alex trebek died a while ago like
we've got to find someone yeah
maybe it's ken jennings maybe it's miami
like maybe she won't just do the college
thing even though she is like famous in
other ways she's really like after a big
bang theory i feel like she doesn't
really act a lot she does like a lot of
philanthropy and she's like very
involved in academia movie that you
watched
jackie that was like 10 years ago it was
like an old lifetime movie and honestly
i was never able to look at her the same
so thank you for bringing that up
um
i'm just saying like she is very
involved in academia she like studied
like neuroscience or some [ __ ] yeah so
she wouldn't be a terrible choice i'm
just saying i just don't want a
celebrity that's all i'm asking yeah i
kind of agree that's all i'm asking okay
but you know what like
we need a host so we need a host
speaking of hosts such a great segue
into today's sponsor
jeff lewis has issues you may know jeff
lewis from the hit bravo series flipping
out or his serious xm radio show jeff
lewis live and now jeff is bringing you
a brand new podcast we think you'll love
called jeff lewis has issues whether
it's drama with family and friends to
parenting or relationships there's no
denying jeff lewis has issues jeff is
joined each week by friends experts and
celebs from tamara judge and jackie
schimel to judge lauren lake and patty
stanger and others as they take notes
as they take a no-holds-barred deep dive
into every detail of jeff's life come
for the laughs and leave feeling so much
better about your own life check out
jeff lewis has issues you can subscribe
now on stitcher pandora apple podcast or
wherever you listen again that's jeff
lewis has issues check it out thank you
for that claudia it's a pleasure
our next story some big news in the
media world only fans is sharing its new
policy banning sexually explicit content
this is so bizarre this is so bizarre so
on thursday the video and image sharing
site only fans announced plans to ban
sexually explicit content starting on
october 1st and that seemed extremely
counter
productive to what they've become really
successful in doing what a lot of
creators have become successful doing
there and only again they're now
clarifying what
it means but it means
a lot of what you think it means right
they do not upload post or display or
publish content on only fans that shows
promotes advertises or refers to
sexually explicit content which means um
intercourse oral genital genital genital
anal generally
it's all the lists of things that you
can't do so pretty much
you're you can post nudity but you can't
post pornography
like
a video yeah
yeah so here's relax
i feel like for a while only fans has
been trying to like not rebrand but just
like let people know like we're a
platform like patreon they've reached
out to us many times like to move our
they did yes they have housewives on
their house aren't doing porn they've
been trying to establish themselves as
like rebecca minkoff did her um
didn't she do her yes that sounds
familiar she dropped her collection
fashion week fashion week collection
sonia morgan's on it a lot of people
have only fans who are famous i don't
think they make a lot of money but it's
like a branding thing they've been
trying for a while to i think compete
with patreon and just become this
platform where people can monetize their
audiences so it wasn't that big of a
shock that they took this standpoint
because it's obviously how they feel but
like it's a really dumb thing to do like
yes why cut off your nose to spite your
face of course you want to have they
don't obviously don't like the stigma
that they have okay i don't think it's
that nice i'm sure like yes they wanted
to become more than just um known for
like sex stuff but they had said it was
something to do with payment processors
like that they couldn't like use some
processors and like banks because of the
content that was shared on the site so
it was like in order to work with those
processors but i don't know if i believe
that i don't know it's just it just
feels shitty like so they got so
popular popular successful like off of
the back of people
who were
doing this and now where are those
people like right that's the thing so i
know i i've read a story every day
former nurse like people quit their jobs
and are making a ton of money and if
there's an audience for something and
there's someone willing to do it who
cares let them do it yeah so they i
think another platform is gonna pop up
and because this is a great opportunity
i wish i started only fans yeah there
were people who were people making
tana mojo posted a couple weeks ago she
made six million dollars in a month
yeah
and she launched another channel then
too
what do you mean she like because her
first channel did so well she's
launching another channel is she yeah
smart but what are people like her gonna
do i know trisha paytas is making like
millions a month
youtubers i mean still a lot of the
people who are on like for the people
who post just like nude photos of
themselves like they're okay that's
still gonna be kosher but i just feel
like only fans will lose a lot of it's
like fans in a sense like people who
just
like stroll looking for stuff like if
they know they're not getting what they
really want i just think like their
users number of users is going to go
down yeah and i just i also think it's
just like a shitty thing to do like to
the height of your popularity so many
people rely on you for incoming like
you're just going to change your whole
business and don't lie i don't it's not
because of that they've been definitely
trying to compete
with a patreon people don't post nudity
on patreon but patreon is a great way
for people with audiences to monetize
that to offer a subscription service to
monetize content
i mean i have no idea what the numbers
are but i feel like only fans is more
successful than patreon 100 but patreon
is really popular like no i know but
like people talk about only fans all the
time like most a lot of people don't
like just talk about patreon in their
days right and that's why only fans is
stupid yeah people are talking about
that also like if it really is about the
payment processors like build your own
payment process totally and like and if
you are wanting to like be taken more
seriously like why don't you start two
different companies like only fans and
only friends or whatever so like one is
for like a patreon type of content and
then one is for nudity yeah it's just
like i don't understand this
i think this is such a dumb business
idea yeah we'll see how it plays out
yeah either it'll destroy only fans or
it'll do exactly what it intended and
like maybe one day we will end up on
only fans instead of patreon like it
will become such a big platform right
but right now i love patreon i will
defend patreon to the death
love and should be like one of their
branded messages you should check out
our patreon at patreon.com morning toast
where we have premium content we just
came upon the one year anniversary of
the grape chili cook-off which is just
so making me feel like now that we've
hit one year i'm just like itching for a
rematch
for a re-match i haven't chill it too
it's such a chilly day i have a new
recipe
and i
i'm ready to bring it and i'm ready to
show you guys what i've been working on
do you agree that today is a chili day
it is i need to get meat me too that's
the hardest part yeah speaking of
patreon i just wanted to say so
one of my favorite things is that
whenever someone gets fired from a
reality show they always immediately are
like it's fine i got an offer to do my
own show
um
what's her name elizabeth vargas has me
and brian
oh bro scared the [ __ ] out of me did he
eat that whole rest of the bone
i guess she'll find out when he takes a
dump no but like he couldn't be barking
if he was choking no it's in his mouth
oh my god like a little cigar come on
here pup okay so elizabeth vargas one of
me and brian's favorite things to do is
send back her stories to each other
because she's always saying like met
with the producers today she's
continuing this charade that she's
getting her own show when like first of
all nobody gets her own show especially
not a one-season wonder
i wasn't i wasn't worried so then also
kelly dodd is like you know i'm getting
my own show blah blah but then yesterday
her and rick announced that they're
starting a podcast on patreon and they
like made this turnt video in their
backyard and it was i'm sorry it was so
funny like i was laughing my ass off um
so kelly dodd joined patreon that was
just all i wanted to say
we welcome all creators but head over to
patreon.com
the morning test are you ready for our
fifth and final
oh i cleared out our triangles hold on i
think it's worth getting because bruce
never heard the song
in live and in person
thank you
root daddy it's okay it's okay my sweet
okay i'm back ready bro you wanna know
why it's okay cause it's the final story
[Music]
do you think these triangles are making
brew feel at peace or like he wants to
kill us he looks peaceful
he's just making some friends outside
the door
okay you guys fifth and final story
i feel like this one goes out to me it's
a little suez news the massive container
ship that shut down the suez canal trade
tries to sail through again
here's hoping they've gotten their ship
together that's funny ever given the
massive vessel that got stuck in the
suez canal will try to sail through it
again friday after sparking a nearly
week-long international shipping
disaster satellite data show the
japanese-owned container ship that
caused billions of dollars in trade
delays in march left a port in egypt and
began voyaging through the red sea
towards the canal with two tugboats
early friday according to the ship
trackingsitemarinetraffic.com
the behemoth was shown inching toward
the narrow waterway alongside dozens of
other ships with no apparent trouble on
friday afternoon but all hands better be
on deck this time shipping experts said
this is crazy you guys crazy honestly of
course i'm praying for a safe voyage but
like i don't know i kind of want to go
over there and sabotage them just so we
can all start talking about the suez
again yeah i'll send luanne down to
distract yeah so obviously it's nice to
be back in the suez i'm happy ever
giving you know it is like a massive
shift they're not just going to retire
because it had a little bad pr yeah no
it's like
you're not going to retire the ship
because the ship is embarrassed yeah
like the chip get back to work like
totally we all screw up like we all have
bad news [ __ ] happens
[ __ ] happens we all cause billions of
dollars in losses happens all the time
happens every day so i'm glad to see you
know you get knocked down you get back
up i get knocked down but i get up again
that's what they should be blaring
through the speakers he never gonna get
you down and i get knocked down but i
get up again
i get knocked down
damn fly sorry sorry flat so flat what
am i paying for that triangle classes
for
you
literally i don't think i've ever
actually related to a character in a
movie more than i do the brother from
step brothers 100 that's me like if my
family's not driving a range rover doing
like organized harmonies i don't want it
no send it back send it back
so good luck to everyone aboard the ever
given um nice to see you guys back out
there and nice to be a part of something
again totally good luck but also not
that much luck you know if things happen
don't worry we're here for you
we'll support you um let's dive into our
tv recap segment which is the real house
was a potomac last night finally ashley
arrived at the house and like brought
the information that we needed in order
for things to move forward and i don't
know i was just feeling really
conflicted it wasn't as i was waiting
for like giselle to get her ass handed
her and she did but for some reason it
didn't feel as good as i wanted it to i
think it's because ashley's like weirdly
on giselle's side i know and it's like
ashley what are you doing and now the
lines are getting crossed because like
i'm agreeing with candace because and
you know what like honestly i never
thought i'd say this like every episode
like i hate her a little bit less like i
i think her friendship with wendy just
because i'm like so riding with wendy
this season is actually like working in
her favor yeah so i just didn't feel
really good but my god did wendy have
some things to say like she went beyond
you know of course you turned out to be
exactly whatever but when she said the
life you're living now
is god giving you like what you deserve
that was just like a
wild thing to say
here's where i sort of
landed landed because i was ready for
the takedown
when they were having lunch and you know
wendy was saying like you hurt my
feelings blah blah blah and i was with
wendy i was right there with them
laughing at her no but then what giselle
said to wendy she
was right when she was like this isn't
cnn cnn like the way that you speak to
us like you think we're like on some
heated show like we're just talking and
it's really true like wendy is a hard
person to
root for because she does do those
things where it's like i have time today
to talk like yeah you know you're right
you're right where and she really treats
it like it's you know
a sound bite as a sound bite a debate
and not
just like a conversation
like the zingers like they just sort of
like
they fall flat for sure they fall flat
so
it's hard and also i felt like
sometimes she she's like obviously has a
lot to be upset about but like in
certain instances i felt like she was
overreacting like knowing that i really
like ashley and i think that like once
she's doing her job like she's here
she's at work for 12 hours and she's
going to earn her information but she
also did come to wendy like in the
kindest way possible and made it all
about her like self being like if
anybody can relate it's me like she
wasn't being holier than now at all like
giselle can't say [ __ ] because gisele
refuses to talk about her own
problems yeah so gisele really can't say
anything but like ashley deals with this
all the time so like her coming to wendy
like it was already out there when when
ashley came to her right and i i
understand that wendy was just already
on the defense especially with ashley
because it actually was sort of taking
giselle aside but like i really don't
think ashley came in
i i think when he was right to be mad at
gizelle for bringing it up to ashley but
like i wish
when he didn't just like explode on
ashley too because i felt like she
wasn't really coming from a delicious i
agree um
but like the fact that there's rumors
about all of the women all the time and
every franchise and like you're gonna
bring up this one this season like and
it's just the person who brought it up
first of all karen younger said it best
we all heard the rumor and only one
person chose to bring it up that's
gizelle that's because she's being
spirited and she is
successful on the show for stepping on
the next of other people so
that's and just the fact that it was
gisele is just extra annoying because
it's like miss girl like you
literally
have the most rumors about you you like
die when anyone brings them up and you
have the most to like you hold things so
close to the best when you have like the
most shady [ __ ] going on and you're
really digging into other people's lives
like worry about yourself and it's true
she does all this to deflect from the
fact that like
are her and jamal together did he have a
baby with someone like what's going on
right but i feel like i mean she
probably thinks she's deflecting from it
but the more she gets involved in other
people's lives the more it's like but
what about you if she just kind of sat
back in this instance like say candace
or someone else like i wouldn't be
thinking about what's going on in her
personal life also when wendy was just
sort of like railing into her and
giselle did the thing where she also did
it on the reunion where she really
doesn't know what to say she sits in
like laughs and she just sits and it's
like
she really has no defense i love it i
love it too i if i were wendy like i
would be so upset i don't think she
was like overreacting in any way i
didn't think anything that she said was
so crazy honestly no but she misdirected
some of her anger at ashley yeah and
then like ashley and candace are
fighting because candace is just like
defending wendy and that was annoying
because like we need them all to band
together but also my god was robin being
annoying like getting involved like
literally no one's talking to you robin
shut up yeah and i'm sorry how dumb does
robin think we are macy's is not wanting
to sell your hats okay
right embellished right
the lie is embellished she's
embellishing she's embellishing the
truth um
so i don't know why i just wasn't
feeling like the satisfaction from that
episode that i was waiting for and it's
because if things didn't go as i planned
ashley was like also the the target of
wendy's anger and i just felt like that
was misdirected yeah it didn't go
exactly as planned but still it's like a
step towards justice um
for team monique and you know karen just
sits idly by like the queen that she is
mia was also being a little annoying
like getting involved it's like you're
new here just don't try and mediate just
sit back and watch especially like when
every time you want to jump in you want
to defend gizelle but it does look like
next week she's calling her out
by the way i just have to say like
karen huger when she was laying by the
pool in her thigh high boots with like
her thigh out i was just like that's a
beautiful thigh like she looks so good i
feel like she's just
and it's supposed to be very difficult
for giselle to see all of this like
karen is really living her best [ __ ]
life like her things with her and ray
are so good she's back on her feet
financially and she was open about that
whole thing her kids are like you know
flourishing out in the world she looks
her best she's got la dum the wigs like
i just feel like she is like such a boss
and giselle is just like kicking herself
like it must kill her to see gisele is
walking around in her fake chanel
cardigan that i saw on instagram
certified fake chanel cardigan and just
like living this fake life like
pretending living in all these lies and
carriages out here living her truth she
shared when she was going through a hard
time with
ray she shared their financial troubles
and now she's just living in her truth
and giselle's still caught up in these
lies i know and i mean we that's how we
see it but i do think that for the
person who's like
the gisele in this situation like
that's not how she sees it she liter she
thinks that she's everything of the sort
and she can't roll up the west wing and
think she's living her best life no she
she does though and like
that's what she believes
i i refuse to believe it i think i don't
think she looks at karen and it's like
this person has everything i want well
i'm just saying from my perspective
that's what it looks like for mine as
well and karen hugo responded to my
story last night i totally forgot to
tell you i was like so geeking out she
said thank you so much because i just
posted a picture like reminding everyone
karen's a queen right don't forget dude
cause it's hard it's easy to forget yeah
so then she was like thank you so much
and i was like oh i'm obsessed with you
and then she never answered oh i like
blew my load like way too early okay
whatever i don't care i'm just so she
should know now rtms are open and i feel
like i tag her and stuff all the time
like when i go to brian's and i spray
myself with the dom fragrance yeah now
she'll be able to see the content right
okay cool get her on the toast literally
like that would be i think that's
actually up there whenever we say like
kelly clarkson like
karen hugher on the show is a part of
that especially for like dream
housewives guests also
karen was on bravo chat room
with gisele
and kind of porsha was mediating this
conversation between them karen posted
the clip on her instagram they didn't
really get anywhere karen was just being
funny like i thought the show was like
cancelled i thought it was too
honestly like the idea that there's an
after show like for the talent to talk
is like not a bad idea but first of all
the name is so bad
and i just feel like they were like
weird like nobody wants to hear from
gizelle and like nobody wants like your
zoom content they gotta get in studio
but then it's like
they don't live together right the bravo
shows are but they need
porsha was a perfect casting i don't
think gisele was a good choice no i
think it needs to be like someone young
and like nosy
like
i don't like someone from southern charm
like you know what i mean i just feel
like it wasn't the right cast like
that's like what hannah berner
was supposed to be yeah yeah but she and
then what happened to kate
i don't know i it's just i thought we
were i thought that was behind us i
thought it was a quarantine thing
it should have stayed in quarantine yeah
that and like my knitting and the tie
dying
yeah those yeah um so that was a tv
recap and i do believe that is all she
wrote that is all that she wrote for
today but we'll be back tomorrow we have
bathroom paradise on tonight i will i'll
be watching until i can't watch you know
mo okay you know thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are if you're still listening this
welcome to the society uh if you're
still listening i can't think of an
emoji so just leave a b
for brew a b like the letter b or the
animal b
oh the letter b okay the letter b thank
you so much for the clarification post
that on our instagram love you guys have
a great day bye bye